joining me now is a good buddy uh a
longtime friend of the program as well
he guest hosted way back
in 2014 and here we are in 2020
joining me here in advance of his movie
super intelligence
with uh melissa mccarthy and james
corden which is going to be on hbo max
on thanksgiving day my buddy
bobby cannavale how are you bobby hi
rich well thanks nice to see you you
look great
you look good too what's with the is the
beard for the role that you're you're
the beard is for the role that i'm doing
here i'm in australia so i'm um
so i i grew the beard for this job and
also really to commemorate the lousiest
year ever
um i'll always know what year whenever i
see that movie i'll know what year it
was
because it's a big beard you got going
on
you're in australia um you're 19 hours
ahead of me do you know if the jets have
lost yet then
do you know if they've lost i don't but
but i'm gonna go out on a limb and say
they did
and not only did they but they probably
lost badly
do you know that i haven't do you know
that i haven't watched i haven't watched
a single jets game this year
because i just can't i like i can't add
to the
crappy year that we've had by actually
exposing my eyes to that horror
okay can't so if you want i can would
you like me i can summarize you know
generally
you don't have to you know why because
i'm on a thread and that's all i got to
do is follow the thread
i've got a couple threads you're one of
them okay um
but yeah i've got another thread with
joe lowe and my brother and my friend
steven girgis and
like it's really funny because i will
watch you know i watch football on
monday morning here
6 a.m and um and so i'm watching i watch
football i watch all the games except
for the jets like i don't even
i don't even do um i don't even do
what's the what's the
thing um uh red zone because i don't
wanna i don't wanna accidentally see
them
so i just go i just follow other teams
and then i just
follow the thread and the thread is
hysterical yeah it's just
it's um yeah again you way back
in the day when you were on my podcast
prior to
show yeah you came up with the phrase
code tidy bad that there you and and we
kind of made it that
that sort of uh that jingle that's uh
zest
soap jingle you're not fully bad unless
you're co-tighty bad
like making this guy look like uh bear
bryant i mean
it's incredible i mean kotak does kotai
looks like a genius compared to what's
happening over there
now i mean i don't quite understand like
like
okay it's no secret my movies aren't
exactly like
you know i'm no tom cruise right like
like like
like they don't make a ton of money i'm
in some good movies that i like i'm a
fan of but they're let's say they're
niche movies let's say
yeah i don't understand like like
like it should you shouldn't be allowed
to be a niche nfl coach
right i mean like is adam gase a niche
nfl head coach i mean if you want
somebody to lose
every game yeah call that guy right
i i know your compromise i know you
can't no no no no no
i don't want to say that because i i
think you're better at what you
do than what adam gase is and what he
does
so i don't know if i want to buy that
analogy bobby you know i mean i don't
oh that's kind of you uh but but but i
mean
he couldn't pull off jeff rossetti for
is his life depended on it
if that was a version of nfl coaching
you know what i'm saying like i wouldn't
i wouldn't
you know how do you lose that many games
and
and and and and and remain in any
discussion
ever again about doing this job
i mean what's the difference i mean i
could lose nine games in a row
i can do that you know you know what's
funny like not to not to pivot here but
it reminds me
but it sort of reminds me of uh i
promise you this is a natural pivot but
in the movie in the super intelligence i
have this scene with ken griffey jr
and okay dude it's awesome like the
movie takes place in seattle and i play
the biggest ken griffey junior fan
so melissa mccarthy works it out that
you know we go to a
mariners game and we're in the box and
ken griffey jr comes and watches the
whole game with me
so ken came out for one day
and um he came out to shoot for one day
flew his own plane to atlanta
after a round of golf flew up and then
shot all day with me
guy looks like he looks like he just
retired like he looks amazing right
anyway we spent the whole day talking
about baseball it's like a dream come
true asking this guys questions but like
you know i'm a yankees fan in the end
i'm a yankees fan yeah so it had to come
up eventually you know me i'll just say
it like it is
so i was like you know you never beat us
right i mean you didn't yeah
you didn't you didn't you didn't win you
know we we've got
27 championships so i kept on saying and
he would go
he would go you know my teams were
pretty good you know you guys you guys
had a lot of breaks coming away i
remember
saying that and then i said um i kept
saying you know we have we got 27
championships we got 27
championships and he finally like he
kind of lost his temper with me and he
goes
he goes you know you didn't you don't
have any championships he says to me you
you actually don't have any
championships
because you never played the game and i
said that's funny because see the way i
look at it is
i have the exact same number of
championships as you do
and he he did not like that
but but i just i just think he did not
like that he did not in terms of liking
it or not liking it
he did not like it but it just made me
think like i was
just been talking about adam gase i was
like i know these guys
it's not an easy thing like you know we
can sit here all day and talk about how
crappy a coach right certain guys are or
whatever and
it's not an easy thing i couldn't do it
but again
i mean you and i could coach the jets to
an 0-9 record
i don't i don't understand and i have a
feeling that players might like me
better actually they might actually have
a better time
because i got jokes i got stories i got
hollywood stories
you know what does adam gase have got
nothing you know he's got like stories
about working with peyton manning when
peyton manning already had one foot in
the hall of fame
with cutler he could talk about cutler
his days with cutler in chicago
yeah you know the problem with the jets
is now is is what always is the problem
is
it's like just when you think they can't
get any worse they get worse
and then it's hard to find somebody who
wants that job
like here's that job here's here's the
thing because i know again you're down
in
in australia i'm here with bobby
cannavale on the rich eisenhower i know
you're in australia
so you might not be getting a lot of
college football news
but trevor lawrence despite getting
covet 19
looks as great as ever
and the jets have done more than half of
the hard work
to get there and the tough thing is that
means sam darnold has to go
which is not his fault and he does not
need to be
talked about like this and all i've been
doing on my show bobby
is talking about how this has to happen
the tanking for trevor has to happen
they have to
get this kid because but a couple of
thoughts about this kid
number one isn't he pulling an eli
doesn't he not want to play for the jedi
eli when you basically say here's your
fur coat stand next to joan namath and
we can make 15 commercials
right like that's if he pulls an eli to
go to
jacksonville that's not happening he
will go to new york city
and he will be broadway trevor and it
will be phenomenal
and the way when you say who's going to
coach this team
you basically say to every coach in the
united states
who it wants to get in the nfl who wants
to be hooked up with trevor lawrence
for the next 15 years in new york city
raise your hand
and they will come from everywhere this
is the way out
for so many different ways said this
before
and the jets just the jets just they
they destroy the souls they've destroyed
the souls of so many quarterbacks in the
past
i remember running into shakhtar at a
jets events when darnold was a rookie
and i said to him hey man what do you
think and he said you know
of all these guys they say sam is they
say darnold's the smartest
and he's going to be the best he's the
real deal and look what's happened
i mean we're not going for the poor guy
i feel bad for him
there's something in the system like
part of me thinks we should
trade that pick and and get like a
ridiculous haul back
and get a free agent quarterback like oh
i think
if you trade him you better trade like
you can't you just cannot
watch him do what he's probably going
to do in the nfl for someone else when
you had an
opportunity to get him for yourself and
earned the right seriously again while
you're while you're
you know this is my one of my favorite
phrases from our our area where we grew
up
while you are gallivanting in australia
avoiding the yet square on your national
red zone
we're all living it and they are earning
the right to take trevor lawrence
week in week out they came so close to
beating belichick on monday night
football
and then 13 points in a fourth quarter
they come back
joe flacco looks terrible i mean it's
it's not gonna coach him rich who's
gonna coach questions
oh i don't know the answer to that i
don't know if they're definitely gonna
keep that but they're gonna if they're
gonna end up with the first pick
right so do you think that they're
waiting to make sure that they lose all
the games
so that they can then get the right
coach correct they have to
and they've held arnold out the last
couple weeks which is the right way to
go but they're not you know
in all honesty they're not trying to
tank they really tried to win that
monday night game and they're trying
every week
they just don't have the firepower and
then one stupid coaching maneuver after
another
you know and it's not just all gates
either it hasn't been great but
the the future is trevor it really is
trevor and clemson could beat the jets
no i think they don't beat clemson
they'd destroy them
yeah really oh yeah yeah yeah and the
nfl team would destroy the best college
team every day of the week
and twice once all right i think so too
normally but again they're gasy you know
what i mean
they're gay you got kotati now it's gay
i mean i like the scan of code tidy
because it's
not a good scan but that's what makes it
a good scan like
it's a kind of a loser scan but and
casey's a little too obvious
but um yeah oh god i got bobby carnaval
here in the rich in show i see your
savages in the box t-shirt that you're
wearing right there little yankees and i
just
mentioned that you worked with ken
griffey jr on this
show because and i'm pleased he didn't
throw back in your face that he scored
the winning run of the playoff game that
ended mattingly's career
he didn't know that did happen he did
not mention that he's a class actor
you know i'm joking you know like he he
really didn't get mad but like we had a
pretty good ribbing back and forth
that's good
and i gotta say like hours and hours and
then i think he had had it when he said
hey man you know you don't have any
championships the way he said it
bro it was like we were in a schoolyard
like we were ready to throw down
he was just tired of it he was tired of
me saying hour 27
our 27th uh so
it's gotta be hard to be a professional
athlete you know i'm playing a
professional athlete this thing i'm
shooting here
and um and in it i have all these
references to
you know how what a pain in the ass it
is to be a retired athlete because
you can't go out you know you just got
to deal with knuckleheads all the time
just telling you what they would have
done and you know
i must be i must be like just a classic
example of
that kind of a fan because um
it's tough man it's tough when like it's
tough when your team is that bad and you
go
i mean i know i can't play football but
i just feel like i have the right
you know i mean they have not won they
have not won
in my lifetime and i'm 50 now it's
i mean i'm like i'm going to be one of
those cubs fans
i don't want to be one of those cubs
fans you know
i don't want to be my buddy tommy
ocean's you know dad who
didn't get to see his team you know win
it all
yeah so tell me about the movie what uh
tell me about super intelligence it says
mccarthy and her husband ben falcone
directed it right
yeah yeah we shot it a couple of years
ago in atlanta and it's uh
it's basically uh the idea is uh
she is the most average person in the
world and
she is gets kind of selected by this ai
that becomes that gets into like all of
her devices
and gets into the government's devices
and is going to shut down the grid for
the world um and the ai
has um is is represented by the form of
james corden's voice
because she's such a fan of james corden
he um
he is he takes on the voice of the a.i
um and he's going to destroy the world
and shut down the grid
unless he can because he's given up on
humanity and so unless he can um
he can see that humanity is worth saving
um he's gonna just he's gonna end it all
and so she
um she has to set out to prove to him
that the world is worth saving that love
is
more powerful than anything else and i
represent believe it or not
that love of her life okay can you
believe it i mean
i mean i don't when i when you first see
me
you might think i'm gonna murder a bunch
of people but guess what i don't in this
movie so that's why i did it
because because i was i couldn't believe
it i was like is she really asking for
me
luckily i know melissa so i had to have
like she texted me hey you want to do
this movie with me will you play my will
you play the love of my life and i was
like do i murder you
in the end and then she was like no i
want you to play a good guy because i
never get these parts
so um it was really fun and um it was
really really fun she's a great actress
and she's a lot of fun and
she and her husband have a good little
cottage industry they're making movies
together
gene smarter brian tyree henry
that's right yeah that's good it's on
hbo max premiering on thanksgiving day
and um and that's called super
intelligence everybody do that
uh go check it out uh starting on
thanksgiving day
um before i let you go sir can you tell
me a good pacino story
i know you've you've kind of you worked
with them on broadway right you've
you've yeah you live with them in l.a
did you crash in this place or something
like that
i mean no i haven't crashed that is have
a question this place
but you worked with him on broadway it
really offered it to me but i adore him
you know and
you got a good story during um i've got
a couple of good stories well you know
for one thing you know uh he was
thrilled to know that i played poker
like when i first
met him he was like you got to come to
my pokemon and i was like yeah
i love it you know i got to poke again
myself and he was like you gotta come
you gotta come
and i showed up the first time i showed
up to his poker game it was incredible
because before i got there
al was the youngest guy at that point
so so so like
now like i'm pretty sure he just wanted
to get the mean
average down of the uh of the guys so
that you know
uh so so so we have these great games
and
you know he's a really incredible guy
you know because his friends you go and
like it's not like you get there and
it's like oh
elliott gould you get there and it's
it's not bad at all it's like
you know frank frank's not kidding 95
and he gave al his first job delivering
papers
and that's who you're playing cards with
it's the greatest man and you know like
old friends of his from the actors
studio and you know
they like they don't play for you know
like you're literally raising 50 cents
you know and um and i guess the
i guess the point of that story is just
to tell you that like that guy's true
blue with his friends like
that's great friends from when he was a
kid and uh
and we play and he always gets a hotel
suite and we play
and then we order from um we ordered
from either katz's
or um carnegie deli and then we take we
take a little break
and we eat these you know massive
sandwiches
and um and then and then and then
usually
i gotta always like i usually i have to
like push the time
that we eat because i know that after
the sandwiches
game's over pretty soon after that you
know what i mean
it's like there's only one there's only
one bathroom in the suite you know so
you guys gotta go home
you know uh but it's the it's the
greatest that's the greatest i love the
guy so much
and um and he's just really generous he
always has been with me and you know
during this time this terrible time
we've been just corresponding and he's a
he's a great
writer i mean he writes me these long
long letters and they're
i hope he writes his memoirs one day
because he's a great writer and a great
recollector of stories from his life
fantastic
and are so are you still doing your
fantasy league with rudd and you
mentioned joelo as
yeah i'm in first place buddy you are
yeah i'm in first place but uh but
although i got russell wilson so that's
kept me in first and
that's starting to get a little shaky i
hope that i don't know what's happening
over there but that the running game
seems to be
it's getting better getting better
they're getting healthier so you got
russell
and then um who else do you have wilson
russell i got todd gurley i got
daryl henderson i've got zeke but you
know
i know he's incredible zeke's a monster
isn't he though like even with that team
he just
he's just they just feed him the ball
he's kind of guaranteed you just plug
him in
okay i know he's well she got um and
then i got
i don't have great receivers i've got
godwin but he's been hurt a lot this
year i've got godwin i've got robbie
anderson
you know catches 11 passes a game and
never gets in the end zone wouldn't that
be great if he was still a jet
for crying out loud you know for matt
rule who they told with
i don't want to go down that wormhole
one more time yeah i got i got eric
hebron i've got the
baltimore defense i've got um
it's pretty good scene and what's the
name is it still is it still the same
name
of your team or just the tip just the
tip is yeah
i think it's just still yeah it's still
just the tip just one word
j-u-s-d-a-t-i-p
i'm never going to grow up rich
what do you want huh they never get they
can't take my kids away you know not for
just
not for having a not for having a
juvenile sense of humor i don't think
they can take the kids away
bobby you are the best man have a great
uh thanksgiving holiday season down
under
um that's on super intelligence let's do
this more often man i miss you
i miss you too send susie my best okay
rose that's uh bobby cannavale here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here